there is real concern at nasa tonight
about a huge
chunk of chinese space junk that could
be on top of us before long
correspondent phil keating has details
tonight
from miami good evening phil good
evening brett another
chinese spent rocket actually plummeted
out of control
just last year raining debris and
damaging some buildings
in the african nation of ivory coast
fortunately nobody was hurt but as far
as space junk goes and there's a lot of
it up above us
this one is enormous it weighs 21 tons
the core rocket stage is circling earth
out of control
and could fall somewhere within the next
several days possibly
as soon as this weekend or monday the
big rocket blasted off last wednesday
from south china it's one of 10 more
planned launches
all of it for china's ambition to build
its own
chinese space station it was a
completely successful launch
but the size of the long march 5 core
stage rocket
about 100 feet long and 16 feet wide
is far larger than the usual piece of
discarded rocket debris
which usually just burns up in earth's
atmosphere
upon dissent we don't know where it's
going to land
it could land anywhere as far north as
new york city
and as far south as new zealand but
anything in that band would be
fair game according to the defense
department u.s space command
is actually tracking the rocket from
vandenberg air force base in california
but says its exact entry point won't be
pinpointed until hours within its
reentry
there are two more launches scheduled
from china in the coming weeks and will
send cargo and three astronauts to the
core module
which is about the size of a five-story
building this is graphic animation
of the final chinese space station
product which is
going to end up being about a quarter of
the size of our current
international space station now since
most of our planet
is ocean 71 it is likely that any pieces
that don't burn through the atmosphere
but came out come on down to earth
could splash down in one of our oceans
but there is the threat that large
pieces could like last year
rain down on inhabited areas brett i'm
sure you remember 1979
lab parties where everybody wore their
helmets i would recommend you get
yours all right i'll be looking up uh
phil thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else